dites-nous vous qui vous aimeriez avoir
à votre mariage hashtag et péter bryan à
pédales il a décrit par les cadets y
avait un mariage avec qui non il y avait
bataillé fontaine parce que je travaille
a vécu à l'époque très fort lequel paul
yav avoriaz jean pierre pernaut non
j'étais atef donc fort tf1 quoi et toi
pascal y avait qui il s'était marié a
pas longtemps à moi je veux pas te dire
parce que déjà je n'ai pas invité mais
c'est vrai ça petit soin de ne pas
inviter je suis quelqu'un d'assez
discret avec la famille juste la famille
oui beaucoup beaucoup la famille et moi
je sais qu'il y avait huit mille
personnes 80 non c'est vrai voilà je
vous y avez qui aujourd'hui c'est le
maire il y avait patrick d'audel patrick
bedell louis baudel godbout des as c'est
qui ce maître boulanger mais j'étais à
france soir le poids de son nez ses
personnages des juristes de presse
écrite pour c'était mon voisin que je
mets bien mettre au boulot on sait qu'il
va y avoir des gens maintenant je veux
je sais pas si je vais me remarier ah
oui parce qu'il paraît que c'est bien
parti
c'est très bien assez tous les voyants
sont au vert non j'ai 56 ans me remarier
à quoi bon vous êtes trop maria quel âge
65 ans et maria pas longtemps voilà on
va pas oui j'ai pas contre l'idée riz
les plus jeunes que vous je suis
toujours optimiste donc pourquoi pas et
vient de battage pour le marié un vrai
et j'en veux dire moi ça me rappelle un
titre s'il n'y a pas d'âge pour aimer
quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas demain la veille que je vais
faire un mariage en effet énormément
dans le passé en animation et croyez moi
c'est génial
allez vous allez voir et on a une petite
surprise pour la cgt pas qu'on te
souhaite tout le bonheur du monde
toi a moqué en écho j'espère que tu bats
épouser et milquet en fac de technologie
[Applaudissements]
les salles sur son mariage où tout le
monde est un talent à suivre ou pas tu
l'a rencontré il était chez le boulanger
je connais c'est un enfer
ce prix nous demandent des blacklists
bâclé sur les haies les chansons qu'il
faut absolument pas passées et seniors
il ya du lady gaga et du patrick
sébastien n'en vend via le maire de la
passion à chaque fois et les démons de
minuit
non mais je vous ai demandé si vous
auriez vous avoir parfois la bretagne à
tout le monde
à l'apéritif et ensuite pour l'europe
mais aussi les personnes qui peuvent
déjà le to data de tpm bc donne tant les
choses variées de people aboutit elle a
montré un bon carnet d'adressés maria
gil verlaine
alors justement la marque je vous
rappelle que j'ai donné une vague ya
deux ans sans rigoler cette vague je
sais pas ce qu'ils ont fait à mon avis
donc fait une demande or un truc un truc
de fou je lui ai offert une bague à 12
ans il ya toujours le mariage nomme jean
size me marie je vous invite ça c'est
sûr
je connais la moitié du mariage
calmez-vous verdet nous aimerions
beaucoup avoir kibodio suntour magasin a
tangué mais sa mort n'a aucun lien avec
la gamme en toi ça m'a bien page amagou
lire également claude ya plein de
collaboration dans l'album et oui ou su
nous a aidés dans l'album de pascal
c'est génial ben alors pascal aussi
ehiosun nommé chanterait pas très bien
je suis vraiment loustics vous quelqu'un
de vivant méfiez-vous je suis très
résistant je viens de chute et j'ai fêté
ses 40 ans de mariage
[Applaudissements]
vous en servez les modeuses ouais c'est
un amour ce mec c'est ouattara 40 ans et
paul c'est vrai mais non sénat -
baccarat et au mon cousin jacky refait
la musique on a chanté du obispo
non c'est pas brillant en fait tu t'es
où le fait c'était entre lyon et
grenoble et je pensais que ça serait
rater bas c'était très bien ouais c'est
vrai alain alors dit qu'il préfère être
malheureux avec moi que re avec
quelqu'un d'autre il vous sert pas
discours oui si vous aviez dans le
discours un peu comme je le dit qu'il
était préféré un mano à mano
et ben je vous trouvez en plus je trouve
très belle aujourd'hui champ que vous
avez passé un bon week-end chambre oui
mais oui je suis à ma grande surprise
oui à lakota c'est la vie samedi samedi
panna cotta voilà pascal ça veut dire
dans le langage série bien faire l'amour
voilà
non parce que tu pourrais tu es dans le
dessert oui bonjour non alors bon je
revenais pourquoi je suis venu là pour
rien et moi nous aimerions qu'ils me
regardent voir qui vous tient au jus
marie j'aimerais bien vous soyez dans la
salle edouard baer et patrick bruel
non c'est pas vrai c'est générale
d'albert qui charrient les invités ce
sera trop fade away on voit très bien
que l'ambiance va coûter très bien elle
va nouvelle va nous sortir patrick
bouchard l'éditorialiste patrick
bouchard oui alors il est comment je
déteste avoir des gens que je ne connais
pas mais je vous parle de star et ben
non justement je veux pas voir des stars
moi je vais avoir des gens que je
connais et que j'aime vous allez me dire
rené descartes non je vais pas me marier
parce que je me suis déjà mariée j'ai
déjà divorcé et salue les primes en fait
aux amis strauss pour moi le mariage
vous vous avez été mariée au raymond
alors jamais d'accord à et bernard
montiel bien entendu à je me marierai
jamais bien sûr en revanche j'ai assisté
à un mariage extraordinaire à dubaï
world et britney houston et mariah carey
bon ben on sait que ce n'est pas ce
week-end
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je peux dire que j'assiste à des
mariages alors moi je regrette d'avoir
gaza où est le problème au mariage avant
mais des requins gris et je sais pas si
vous avez le même problème je suis sûr
que pascal ou benjamin c'est que bon
comme on voit là on passe un petit peu
la télé j'ai toujours roulé mais call me
voir pire il faut que je te présente sur
les mafias avoir les larmes
et là il ya la meuf aces mais commis
devant wam elle prend le micro et chante
devant moi et donc je fais donc après le
fini parce qu'elle fait toute la chanson
c'est pas de fins y compris alors alors
que sur la pensée donc c'est franchement
rêver vois tu la prends pas dans ton
émission et après il ya toujours un
second mariage il ya toujours un mais
client devra se joint project pas tu tu
as aussi pavé quartier c'est toujours
comme ça kenny vous vous aimeriez qu'ils
à votre mariage bat maginet entre bieber
et pascal bieber et pascal oui vous
aurez plus de chances d'avoir pascal
ouais bah pourquoi
bah ouais ou bien justin bieber oui
pourquoi pas donc masse a dépendu du
mari elle prend les deux hommes le bras
long et de sueur pense que je crois
qu'un seul
[Musique]
je préférerais pour tout ça paiera moi
mes amis à mes parents mais je sais pas
payer généralement bien c'est parce que
au design moderne car si vous auriez pu
le faire payer façon que vous aurez
jamais payé de la planète